[موسيقى]
احييكم واهلا بكم الى نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء تقدموها لكم ميسون ويهد نبدا
بالعناوين
عشيه ذكرى الحرب التصعيد في اوكرانيا
وتتحدث عن خارطه الطريق
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه سيده اوكرانيا
الاولى تتحدث عن لحظه بدء الهجوم الروسي
على
المفكر الروسي المقرب من بوتين يحذر من
حرب اهليه في اوكرانيا بحال خساره روسيا
الحرب
ارضيه جديده تضرب جنوب تركيا وتقرير يكشف
الخضوع 5% فقط من الابنيه في سوريا لشروط
السلامه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تعليقا على خطط السلام الصينيه
المتوقعه بشان اوكرانيا قالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها تريد التعرف على تلك الخطه
مضيفه انها تتوقع ان يتم الكشف عن
تفاصيلها يوم غد وهو ما اشار اليه مندوب
الصين لدى الامم المتحده هذا واكدت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه انها ستقيم قرار روسيا
بعد اعلان الرئيس بلادمير بوتين تعليق
العمل بمعاهده الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه ستارت
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن تسعى
الى العوده لمسار التفتيش المتبادل وفقا
للمعاهده مشيره الى انها لن تستانف
اختبارات الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه بعد قرار
روسيا وكان بوتين اكد ايضا انه لن يبدا
باجراء اختبارات نوويه كما اكدت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انها ستلتزم بالتوازن
النووي لمعاهده ستارت رغم قرار تعليق
العمل
الازمات مهما كانت عميقه يمكن حلها بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه في نهايه المطاف ندعم استئناف
روسيا واوكرانيا الحوار المباشره في اسرع
وقت ممكن ووقف اطلاق النار والاعمال
القتاليه ووضع ذلك اولويه ويجب ان يبذل
المجتمع الدولي جهودا مشتركه لتسهيل عمليه
السلام الواقع اثبت ان ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا فقم النزاع ولم يجلب السلام
وندعو ايضا الى التخلي عن استغلال
العقوبات الاحاديه وان يكون البديل العمل
على تعزيز سبل الحوار الصين لطالما لعبت
دورا بناء وستصدر عما قريب ورقه حول طريقه
تسويه الازمه واحلال السلام في وقت مبكر
اما فيما يخص العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
قالت واشنطن انها تملك معلومات تشير الى
ان الصين تدرس امكانيه مساعده روسيا في
حربها على اوكرانيا محضره في الوقت ذاته
بكين من القيام بذلك وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتوني اكد ان بلاده لا تخوض
حربا بارده جديده سواء مع روسيا او الصين
من جانبه صرح المستشار الالماني بانه ابلغ
الصين ان ارسالها اسلحه لروسيا لن يكون
مقبولا وعلى بوتر ان يفهم انه لن يتمكن من
الانتصار في هذه الحرب
وهذه صور مباشره مشاهدينا سنتابعها سويا
من موسكو
للاحتفال
بيوم عيد الوطني يوم عيد المقاوم
بل حماه الوطن
اذا نتابع هذه الاحتفالات في موسكو بيوم
حماه الوطن
هذا اليوم الذي يحتفل فيه
الروسيون بيوم حماه الوطن نتابع صوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
وننتقل الان الى هذه الصوره من
عشيه ذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
وتبدو الحركه ضعيفه في كييف وكان ايضا
مراسلنا حذيفه عادل سابقا تحدث بانه اليوم
المشهد يختلف عن الايام الماضيه بسبب
التخوفات مع اي تطورات عسكريه او ميدانيه
من الممكن ان تحصل في ذكرى الاولى لهذه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اذا نتابع صور من روسيا باحتفالات
وبيوكرانيا حركه التنقل في اكياس عشيه
الذكرى الاولى لهذه الحرب على اوكرانيا او
ما تسميها روسيا العمليه العسكريه على
اوكرانيا
الرئيس الاوكراني خلال مؤتمر صحفي جمعه
بالرئيس الوزراء الاسباني بيدرو سانشيز ان
حديث الصين عن اوكرانيا هو ليس بالامر
السيء
السابق لاوانه الحكم على خطه السلام
الصينيه اعتقد بشكل عام ان حقيقه ان الصين
بدات تتحدث عن اوكرانيا وبدات بارسال بعض
الاشارات ليس بالامر السيء من المهم
بالنسبه لنا ان تكون جميع البلدان الى
جانبنا الى جانب العداله ان تتحدث الصين
عن اوكرانيا هو الخطوه الاولى وهذا امر
ليس بسيء
هذا وتار مصطلح الثالوث النووي تكهنات
كثيره في الاوساط السياسيه بعدما تعهد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بتحسينه
وتطويره خلال اجتماع موسع لقيادات وزاره
الدفاع نشاهد تفاصيل احدث اسلحه الثالوث
النووي التي تملكها موسكو
الثالوث النووي مصطلح اشعل التوتر من جديد
في اوكرانيا بعد ان تعهد الرئيس الروسي
بتطويره للحفاظ على سياده روسيا ووحده
اراضيها
هذا المصطلح اثار تكهنات عده في الاوساط
السياسيه لما قد يشكله من تهديد للعواصم
الغربيه ففي العقيده العسكريه الروسيه
يتكون الثالث النووي من ثلاثه انواع من
الاسلحه الردعيه هذه الاسلحه تحمل رؤوسا
نوويه مهمتها الردع الاستراتيجي الشامل
ارضا وجوا وبحرا
طويل كما كان الوضع من قبل سوف الاهتماما
متزايدا لتقويه الثالوث النووي وسنواصل
الانتاج الضخم لانظمه كينجال الجويه التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومن البحر سنبدا
في الامداد بكميات كبيره من صواريخ سيركون
والسلاح الاول منها هو الصاروخ سارمات
الارضي الذي يحمل عشره رؤوس نوويه وهو
نظام صاروخي استراتيجي من الجيل الخامس
ويتم استخدامه من قواعد ارضيه بضرب اهداف
على بعد الاف الكيلومترات باستخدام انواع
مختلفه من الوسائل الثابته والمتحركه
اما السلاح الثاني فهو مجمع صواريخ كنجال
الجويه التي تفوق سرعه الصوت والتي تعتبر
ايضا من احدث الاسلحه التي طورتها موسكو
ضمن الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تطلق من
الجو
حيث تبلغ سرعه هذا الصاروخ 12 الف كيلو
متر في الساعه وهو قادر على تدمير الاهداف
بمدى يصل الى 200 كيلومتر واخيرا سلاح
السيركون البحري الذي يعد اخطر اسلحه ثالث
الرضع النووي والذي لقب بالصاروخ الذي لا
يقهر حيث تكمن خطورته في الغواصات التي
تحمل والتي يمكنها التخفي في اعماق البحار
لاشهر قبل ان تطلق صواريخها كما انه قادر
على الوصول الى سرعه تساوي تسعه ارقام ماخ
ويبلغ مداه اكثر من الف كيلو متر لا يقتصر
الامر عند هذا الحد فروسيه تمتلك ايضا
انواعا مختلفه من السفن والغواصات الحربيه
المزوده بصواريخ نوويه عابره للقارات
والتي قد تلحق دمارا هائلا بشواطئ العدو
ومنشاته الساحليه سلطان العيبان العربيه
في اول مقابله لوسيله اعلاميه عربيه قالت
سيده اوكرانيا الاولى اولينا زيلينسكي ان
لا احد يجهزك كسيده اولى خصوصا في زمن
الحرب مضيفه انها تحاول كل جهدها للانتصار
في هذه الحرب ضد روسيا
وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا احد يجهزك
على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده اولى خصوصا
في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك لحقيقه انه
يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله في حاله حرب
ولكن كما قال داروين ليس الاسرع او الاقوى
من ينجو ولكن اولئك الذين يمكنهم التكيف
لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل وفق متطلبات العصر
حسب مقتضيات الظروف التي نعيش فيها احاول
ان افعل كل ما يجب علي من اجل تقريب
انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر اهميه هو التحدث
عن اوكرانيا عن الاوكرانيين في اي منصه
حيث اتيحت للفرصه للتحدث
كما تحدثت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى للعربيه
عن لحظه الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا انه
تم من كل الجهات ودون سابق انذار مشيره
الى انها كانت لحظه انفصال عائلتها
لانشغال زوجها
بالحرب
لقد هجموا علينا حقا من جميع الجهات في
الصباح الباكر وكان اصعب شيء بالنسبه لي
هو كيف اقول للاطفال كان علي ان اذهب الى
الغرفه واوقظهم واخبرهم بان الحرب قد بدات
لكن لحسن الحظ لقد استيقظوا بالفعل وفهموا
بالفعل كل شيء لم يكن علي ان اخبرهم باي
شيء ومنذ تلك اللحظه بدا زمن فيصل عائلتنا
بعد ذلك لم يروا والدهم الا بعد بضعه اشهر
اليوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى نتذكر ذلك
التاريخ لا يوجد تاريخ انتهاء لهذه الحرب
لكن لها تاريخ بدء وكان ذلك في الربع
والعشرين من فبراير
العام الماضي وسوف نتذكر دائما هذا اليوم
الرهيب
المقابله كامله مع سيده اوكرانيا الاولى
تاتيكم غدا الجمعه في تمام الساعه الرابعه
10:30 بتوقيت جرينتش الخامسه والنصف
بتوقيت السعوديه
ايضا في مقابله مع العربيه قال المفكر
الروسيه
المقرب من بوتين ان بلاده دخلت في حرب لم
تكن تريدها ولن تخطط لها وقال في لقاء خاص
مع العربيه ان العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كان من المفترض ان تكون خاطفه
لكن ذلك كان مستحيلا بسبب العلاقات الجيده
لاوكرانيا
اعتقد ان روسيا في حاله حرب طويله جدا
ومخيفه جدا وجديه للغايه
لعمليه عسكريه محدوده محليه خاطفه وسريعه
للغايه وراميه الى تغيير النظام السياسي
في اوكرانيا واجبارها على رفض الانضمام
للناتو والامتناع عن العسكره وعن
الايديولوجيه النازيه ولكن تبين بعد مرور
بعض الوقت ان ذلك لم يتحقق اي انه من خلال
تلك الاهداف وبتلك الوسائل وضمن المده
التي تم التخطيط فيها كان ذلك مستحيلا
لانه اندماج اوكرانيا في الناتو والغرب
كان اعماق لقد تم الرهان على عدد من
السياسيين المعارضين الاوكرانيين لكن هذا
الشيء لم ينجح اذ تم تقييدهم وتحيدهم على
الفور وجدت روسيا نفسها في حاله حرب لم
نقم مستعدين لها ولم نعول عليها
ان روسيا اصبحت امام مفترق طرق ولا يمكن
لها ان تخسر الحرب او تتخلى عن المناطق
الجديده مشيرا في لقائه مع العربيه الى ان
خساره روسيا في اوكرانيا تعني اندلاع حرب
اهليه
في هذه الحرب التي نخوضها مع الغرب هناك
مفترق الطرق التالي انها حرب خطيره لدرجه
ان روسيا لا يمكن ان تخسرها بل يمكنها ان
تنتهي لا يمكن ان تقول حسنا سنتخلى الان
على المناطق التي استولينا عليها حين ذلك
سيحدث انفجار داخلي ستار روسيا في حرب
اهليه لا يمكن لروسي ان تخسر باي شكل لانه
بالتراجع خطوه الى الوراء سنتراجع الف
خطوه الى الوراء ستقاتل روسيا حتى النهايه
ببساطه لاننا لا نستطيع التوقف لا يمكننا
ان نخسر لن نكون راضينا الا عن تحرير
اوكرانيا باكملها من النخبه السياسيه
المواليه لحلف مهما كان ثمن
ميدانيا رغم القتال الشرس الذي يستمر منذ
اسابيع بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
بهدف السيطره على مدينه باخموت الا ان
الجنود الاوكرانيين في وحده الدبابات
المرابطه بالقرب من بخت ما زالوا في
مواقعهم
[موسيقى]
وهذه صور مباشره مشاهدينا من برج افل مضاء
بالعالم الاوكراني عشيه الذكرى الاولى
للحرب في اوكرانيا اذا فرنسا تضيء برج
ايفل في الوان العلم الاوكراني عشيه
الذكرى الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا لطالما
فرنسا كانت دائما مواقفها وتصريحاتها هي
باهميه عن اهميه دعم اوكرانيا
وجعلها صامده في هذه الحرب التي تشنها
روسيا عليها
وطبعا على الرغم من بعض التفاوت في وجهات
النظر بين الدول الاوروبيه حول اوكرانيا
الا ان الكل موحد ومتوحد حول فكره دعم
اوكرانيا حتى تبقى صامده
وهناك يبدو قرار ايضا اوروبي وامريكا بعدم
السماح لبوتين بان ينتصر في هذه الحرب
والان لنتابع الاوضاع في اوكرانيا وايضا
ابرز المواقف في روسيا ينضم الينا من
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه من
كاف حذيفه عادل من الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه موفد العربيه حسين قنيبر ومن
كراماتورز مفرد العربيه ايضا احمد باكاتو
زملائنا منتشرين في كافه المناطق ليطلعون
على كل التطورات الحاصله عشيه ذكرى هذه
الحرب وطبعا العربيه ستكون في تغطيه شامله
ايضا في يوم ذكرى الحرب في الرابع
والعشرين اي غدا سابدا معك احمد بغاتو
اليوم يعني منذ قليل وصلت الى كراماتورز
كنت في ازيوم هل يمكن ان تصف لنا مشاهداتك
على الطريق كيف كانت تبدو الاوضاع من
ازيوم الى كريم
نعم بالفعل ميسون يعني وصلنا قبل قليل الى
هنا وكما تشاهدين ظلام دامس في كافه ارجاء
المدينه تلك المدينه التي تعرض لقصف اكثر
في وقت لوقت طويل لكثير من المباني مهدمه
وجدنا في الطريق العديد من
الاليات العسكريه وكذلك الحافلات والبيوت
التي استهدفها القصف بصوره كبيره اسفل ذلك
عن تدمير الكثير منها ايضا هناك حظر
للتجوال بدايه من الساعه التاسعه يعني بعد
حوالي 45 دقيقه سيكون هناك حظر للتجوال
حتى صباح اليوم التالي هناك سماع بصوره
مستمره لاصوات القصف الذي يسقط على ما
نعتقد في بخموت القريبه من هنا لكن اذا
تحدثنا عن الوضع العسكري الوضع العسكري ما
زال على حاله محاولات للتقدم في مناطق
كوبيانسك في شرق كيف وكذلك ايضا الايمان
وبخموت التي تشهد الاشتباكاتها القويه في
ضخمه كل طرف يتحدث عن انه يحقق
انتصارات الجانب الروسي يقول انه يتقدم
بصوره كبيره وكذلك الجانب الاوكراني يقول
انه ضد هذه الهجمات ايضا كان هناك تسع
ضربات صاروخيه استهدف بعضها خاركيف 28
غاره جويه تقول ايضا القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هنا ان هناك
الطائرات المسيره الروسيه تحاول معرفه
بدقه اماكن تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه عن
طريق الطائرات بدون طياره التي ترسلها لكن
يتم التصدي لها بالمضادات التي يستهدف هذه
الطائرات وتم اسقاط اكثر من طائره على ما
تقوله هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه كذلك ايضا
الوضع في شمال
الجبهات الشماليه في اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا
والشماليه الشرقيه لم يتغير الوضع على
حاله لما لم رصد مجموعات هجوميه من جانب
القوات الروسيه لذلك فالاشتباكات الاكبر
هي تجري في الجبهات الشرقيه ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها قامت بحوالي اربعه
عشر نعم طلعه جويه بالطائرات المسيره
استهدفت مواقع وتمركزات
لقوات الروسيه في الجبهات الشرقيه وكذلك
اربعه طلعات بالطيارات المسيره استهدفت
مواقع للمضادات
والصواريخ التي تستهدف المناطق الاوكرانيه
هذا بالنسبه
لكراماتورستوم ومشاهدات زميلنا احمد نجاتو
ساذهب الان الى حذيفه عادل في كاذب حذيفه
كنا تبعنا منذ قليل بعض الصور لشوارع
اكياذ تبدو الحركه فيها جدا بطيئه وتبدو
خاليه من
التنقلات هل يمكن ان تصف لنا الاجواء
اليوم
ولماذا هذا التخوف من التنقل اليوم في كاف
تحياتي ميسون لك وللزملاء في الحقيقه يعني
اصبتي هذا هو الواقع هنا في العاصمه كيف
منذ الصباح الباكر وعند
ذهاب الناس الى اعمالهم دائما تكون هنالك
ازدحام كبير جدا على الشوارع اليوم لم
نرصد هذا الزحام كذلك الفتره المسائيه عند
عوده المواطنين من اعمالهم الى بيوتهم
كانت الشوارع خاليه اليوم
لا توجد حركه تذكر في العاصمه اكيد واضح
جدا ان العاصمه هنالك عدد كبير من السكان
العاصمه قد خرجوا منها هذا ما تحدثنا عنه
بالامس مع المواطنين عندما سالناهم ما
الذي سيفعلوه وما الذي يتوقعوه قالوا انهم
يتوقعون عمليه قصف واسعه النطاق من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي وان الصواريخ ستسقط على
كيف باعداد كبيره لذلك اعداد كبيره من
المواطنين اقرروا الخروج من المدينه
واللجوء الى الضواحي المدينه تعلمين ان
طبيعه
التركيبه السكانيه
للمواطنين الاوكرانيين هي انهم يعيشون في
بيوت في الضواحي ويقيمون في المدن لذلك هم
يعتقدون انهم سيكونون في مامن اكثر اذا ما
خرجوا الى الضواحي هذا الامر واضح جدا
للعيان في العاصمه كيف اليوم ايضا كان
هنالك اجراءات وترتيبات من قبل السلطات
المحليه سواء كان في كييف او في كل المدن
الاوكرانيه من يعني حتى في اوديسا على
ساحل البحر الاسود اعلن عمده المدينه عن
بعض الملاجئ التي اوتي بها الى وسط
المدينه ليلجا اليها المواطنين في حاله
عمليات القصف كذلك في هنالك ملاجئ تم
وضعها في مناطق متفرقه من المدينه هنا
نتحدث عن الملاجئ خرسانيه هذه للماره ولكن
ايضا تم نشره طبعا يعني خارطه الملاجئ في
كل هذه المدن المواطنين يعلمون الى اين
يجب ان يذهبوا في حاله حدوث اي عمليه قصف
واسعه النطاق ولكن يعني ايضا طبعا تم
تغيير وضع الدراسه والطلاب لم يذهبوا الى
المدارس وسوف تكون الدراسه عن بعد ولكن
ايضا تحدثت السلطات العسكريه عن كيف سيكون
الوضع وما الذي تتوقعه الاداره الشماليه
في الجانب الشمالي وهنا نتحدث عن الحدود
الفيلاروسيه قالت انها رصدت حركه لجحافل
من الجنود والاليات على الحدود الاوكرانيه
مع منطقه شيرنيغاف وقالت ان هؤلاء هؤلاء
الجنود يرتدون زي القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وهي تتوقع ان يقوموا بعمليات
استفزاز مع القوات البيلاروسيه وذلك طبعا
دوله بلاروسيا الى هذه الحرب وتزوير عمليه
هجوم من قبل القوات من الاتجاه الشمالي
اما عمليه هجوم واجتياح كامل في القوه
فالسلطات تقول انها ستكون عمليه انتحاريه
من قبل موسكو وان هذا الامر الذي لن يوصل
الى اي شيء حذيفه دعنا نذهب الان الى
الحدود الاوكرانيه البولنديه مع زميلنا
هناك حسين قنيبر موف العربيه حسين كنت كما
دائما نذكر بانك اول واصلين كنت الى
الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه عندما بدات
هذه العمليه العسكريه منذ سنه كيف يبدو
الوضع الان اين انت الان متواجد على هذه
الحدود وماذا يمكن ان ترصد لنا خلال
تنقلاتك اليوم
نعم مساء الخير ميسون في مراسله سابقه معك
في مداخله سابقه قبل ثلاث ساعات كنا عندها
معبر مديكا الحدود بين بولندا واوكرانيا
في اقصى جنوب شرق بولندا جئنا الان الى
هنا الى محطه بشميشل وهي محطه القطار
الحدوديه الرئيسيه داخل بولندا لندخل الى
داخل فوجئنا قبل قليل بان هذا التجمع من
الموجودين هنا ليس لمواطنين بولنديين بل
هو
لاوكرانيين لجاوا من
وهم ينتظرون هنا لنقلهم الى مدينه هانوفر
الالمانيه اذا اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
الاوكرانيين يتجمعون هنا في محطه بشمشل في
اقصى شرق بولندا وصلوا من زابوريجيا
الاوكرانيه ويستعدون للتوجه الى هانوفر
الالمانيه حيث يسار الى ترتيب استقبالهم
عائلات باكملها كما تشاهدون من اللاجئين
الاوكرانيين طبعا كنا نعتقد ان وتيره وصول
اللاجئين باتت شبه معدومه لكننا اكتشفنا
ان موجات اللجوء طبعا لم تكن بالاهميه
نفسها كما كانت عليه قبل عام بالتاكيد هي
تراجعت كثيرا لكن اعدادا من اللاجئين
مازال اتصل بالالاف اذا كانت الاعداد
اسبوعيا سابقا تقدر ب 150 الفا من كل
اسبوع قبل عام فهي حاليا حوالى
الف اللاجئ يوميا واحيانا الفيء لاجئ اذا
ما زال هناك لاجئون اوكرانيون يصلون الى
هنا للانتقال من بولندا الى مدن اخرى داخل
بولندا او الى دول اوروبيه اخرى بالمناسبه
محطه القطار هذه هي التي استخدمها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يوم الاثنين الماضي
عندما وصل الى هنا الى جنوب شرق بولندا
تحديدا الى مطار جيوشاوف القريب من هنا ثم
جاء الى هنا الى محطه بشاميل وصعد مع
الوفد المرافق له على متن القطار هنا في
هذه المحطه وتوجه من هنا الى كييف الرحله
استغرقت 10 ساعات ثم عاد من هنا الى
تشميشل ومنها انطلق الى العاصمه البولنديه
وارسو حيث عقد يومين من المحادثات الثلاثه
والاربعاء الثلاثاء مع المسؤولين
البولنديين وعلى راسهم الرئيس دودا
والاربعاء مع مجموعه بوخارست بوخارست 9
المؤلفه من دول اوروبا الش المنضويه ضمن
ميسون والان سنذهب الى موسكو مع زميلنا
عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنى
كنا تابعنا المقابله التي اجريتها مع
الكسندر دوغين هناك تصريح جدا خطير من
قبله عندما قال بانه اذا خسر بوتين في
اوكرانيا سيكون هناك حرب اهليه هل تمكنت
من معرفه على ماذا يعتمد من خلال هذا
التحليل الذي يتحدث عنه في مقابلته معك
مساء الخير ميسون لك والي الزملاء طبعا في
البدايه اسمحي لي بان اشير بان الكسندر
دوكن هو يعني فيلسوف له ابعاد كبيره
بتوحيد روسيا الام ويعتبر ان اوكرانيا هي
من الاراضي الروسيه وان التاريخ الاخير
خلال المئه السنه الماضيه كان قد ابعد
اوكرانيا عن خارطه روسيا هو يؤمن بقضيه
الاتحاد الاورو اسيوي لذلك طبعا دوجن
مواقفه تعتبر قاسيه وتصريحاته كبيره طبعا
هو ينظر
ويحلل المواقف بشكل كبير كان له احاديث
سابقه قبل سنوات تتحدث عن اندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا لذلك طبعا كلامه يحمل على محمل
الجديه بقضيه انه في حال خسرت موسكو هذه
الحرب وهذه الاراضي وعدت ادراجها سيعني
ستحل كارثه في الاراضي الروسيه هذا ما نوه
اليه في سابقاوها اليه العديد من الشخصيات
الرسميه الكبيره التي تلعب دور محوري
قياده البلاد سياسيا طبعا يرى بان خساره
موسكو لهذه الحرب قد يعني تخلق جوا من
محاوله استقلال بعض الجمهوريات من حدوث
صراع داخلي كبير على السلطه بين شخصيات
مواليه للشرق ومواليه للغرب لكن طبعا
ميسون ما لفت انتباهه الى ان دوقني يتحدث
بكل ثقه على انه في جميع الاحوال ان كانت
موسكو ربحت هذه الحرب او خسرتها فان
اوكرانيا لن تكون موجوده على هذه الارض
طبعا يرى بان خساره موسكو بعيده جدا خاصه
بما يخص المناطق الاربعه التي ضمتها يعني
نهايه العامه الماضي طبعا يتحدث عن ان
الزبروجي وخرسون
هي مناطق لا يمكن العوده منها والا طبعا
ستكون وستحل كارثه كبيره في روسيا قد تطال
يعني السمعه الثقيله للعتاد والجيش الروسي
والسلاح الكبير طبعا الحديث مع ديوغن كان
صعبا للغايه لاخفيك ميسون الحقيقه انه عند
نهايه هذا الحوار الذي امتد قرابه
الاربعين دقيقه يعني اصبحت منهكا بشكل
كبير من ثقل المعلومات التي يتحدثوا عنها
هذا الشخص طبعا له جمهوره الكبير في روسيا
له العديد من المنظمات التي يدعى اليها
ويتحدث ويحاضر طبعا لابد ايضا من لفت
الانتباه بان العالم اجمع ميسون يعتبر
بانه الشخصيه وهو العقل المدبر طرحنا على
هذا السؤال هو طبعا يرى بينه وبين يعني
التفكير الصحيح للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين كما وصفه اختلاف كبير طبعا بوتين
قام بانشاء نظرياته يعني
باتخاذ قرار البدء بهذه العمليه العسكريه
بدءا على نظريات دوجن يعني الذي يدعو طبعا
لضم اوكرانيا الى روسيا الام لكن طبعا
هناك خلاف كبير في النظ
مع اقتراب دخول العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا عامها الثاني لم تحقق موسكو
اهدافها المعلنه للحرب فبحسب صحيفه جاردين
البريطانيه انتكاسات كبيره منيات بها
روسيا اولها ان تصور الرئيس الروسي
للعمليه الخاطفه كان خاطئا تحولت لحرب
مدمره لا تعرف نهايتها القوات الروسيه
فشلت في الاستيلاء على العاصمه وتحول
الصراع لحرب استنزاف تسببت بمقتل الالاف
كما يستبعد خبراء عسكريون شنروسيا لهجوم
جديد مهم مرجعين ذلك الى تدهور القدرات
الروسيه بسبب الحرب في المقابل اصبحت
اوكرانيا اقوى واكتسبت انظمه افضل
بالانظمه افضل وتحصل على المزيد من
الاسلحه اما احتمالات القتال شرقي
اوكرانيا فتشمل تكتيف روسيا لوتيره
هجماتها في باخموت خشيته هجوم اوكراني
كبير او لاغراض دعائيه
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
وسائل اعلام امريكيه تؤكد نيه واشنطن
توسعه تواجدها العسكري في تايوان الى نحو
اربعه اضعاف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت اداره الكوارث
التركيه ان هزه بقوه خمس درجات ضربت
انطاكيا قرب الحدود مع سوريا هذا وقال
وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان سويلم ان
بلاده ستوسع تحقيقا بشان مقاولين بناء
المشتبه في انتهاكهم معايير السلامه وذكر
سويلم انهم حددوا هويه
564 مشتبها به حتى الان واعتقلوا 160 فيما
تتواصل التحقيقات مع عدد اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين اذا كانت تركيا المستقره
والمتقدمه دمر فيها الزلزال المباني التي
شيدت تحت اعين الحكومه والرقابه فماذا عن
سوريا التي تعيش منذ 12 سنه ازمه خنقتها
اقتصاديه
وسياسيا مسؤولون في النظام السوري اقروا
بوجود مخالفات كبيره في عمليات البناء في
سوريا كاشفين عن ان 5% فقط من الابنيه في
سوريا خضعت لشروط السلامه خلال البناء منذ
2011 بينما بقيه الابنيه غير معلومه
مواصفات مواد البناء الداخله والمستخدمه
فيها وفقا لعضو لجنه الكود السوري للبناء
عصام ملحم لاحدى الاذاعات المحليه السوريه
ماذا اوضح ملحم قال ان من ينفذ المنشات
الهندسيه في سوريا هم اما مهنيون او
يقاولون واغلب المقاولين لا يمتلكون معرفه
علميه في البناء اضافه ايضا لعدم وجود اي
نظام هندسي او قانون يتابع اعمال التنفيذ
وانما يقتصر التدقيق على مهندس مشرف يستلم
حادثه التسلف في اثناء التركيب ما يشير
لمخالفات ضخمه في البناء بسوريا بالتالي
ايضا تنبا ملحم بخسائر اكبر في حال حدوث
زلزال اخر في سوريا لماذا لان ابنيه
المخالفات في كثير من المناطق غير سليمه
انشائيا كما ان المقاولين يتركون الابنيه
على الهيكل لسنوات طويله وهي عرضه بشكل
اكبر للتاثر بالظروف المناخيه وبالاخص في
المناطق الساحليه حيث يعامل الرطوبه يؤثر
على فولاذ التسليح كما يتسبب بتاكله او
صدقه
خرجوا الى الحياه مجددا بعدما عاشوا اهوال
الزلزال اطفال سوريون في الخيام افتقد
بعضهم الخدمات الطبيه الاساسيه في مخيمات
مدينه اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب موظفوه
مركز صحه المهاجرين المسؤول عن اللاجئين
ومتطوعون اتراك يجوبون الخيام بحثا عن
اطفال لم يتلقوا اللقاح بسبب الزلزال يحيى
متطوع تركي جاء من دوسجه شمالي تركيا
للمساعده في هذه المبادره
سالك نكمل لقاحات ناقصه للاطفال حديثي
الولاده ولمن هم بعمر سته اشهر وتسعه اشهر
و12 شهرا نتفقد الخيام ونقدم خدماتنا لهم
كثير من العائلات السوريه لم تستطع تامين
اللقاحات لاطفالهم بسبب دمار لحق بمراكز
طبيه تعنى بهم
من بيوتنا من الزلزال وجينا لهون على
المخيم باركنا وبنتي ما جبنا لوحات ما في
مراكز لاله صحه المهاجرين الحمد لله
يعطيها العافيه اجو لبنتي هون لا شك كانه
جولاتي المتطوعين وفرت حلا مؤقتا لمئات
الاطفال السوريين لكن الظروف القاسيه
لذويهم تحتاج المزيد من الرعايه والاهتمام
خصوصا في ظل غياب الكثير من الخدمات عنهم
زيدان زنجلو العربيه من مدينه اصلاحيه
غازي عنتاب
ينضم اليه هنا في الاستوديو دكتور خلدون
النبواني المفكر والباحث السياسي دكتور
نبواني اهلا بك معنا لماذا لم تخضع هذه
الابنيه في سوريا لشروط السلامه خاصه منذ
عام 2011 ونحن نتحدث عن مناطق النظام يعني
في المناطق الاخرى التي لجا اليها الناس
مثلا في شمال غرب سوريا موضوع الفقر وايضا
ليس هناك من حكومه مركزيه الى حد ما وهناك
فقر ولكن بالنسبه لمناطق النظام التي تخضع
له لماذا شروط اهلا بك وشكرا للاستضافه
يعني لا شك ان النظام اظن اما قبل عام
2011 يعني هناك نظام ينخره الفساد قبل ان
ياتي زلزال يصدع هذه الابنيه هناك الفساد
وبالتالي يتحدث النظام مثلا عن 12 فرع فيه
ما يقارب 10,000 مقاول وكل واحد لديه
مهندسون ولكن معروف بنيه الفساد وبالتالي
الفساد يعني ان المقاول يمكن ان يتقاضى
اجور كبيره ومقابل ان يعني لا تكون المواد
بتلك الكفاءه التي يمكن ان تحمي البناء
ليس فقط من الزلزال وانما من عوامل الزمن
وبالتالي ما قبل الزلزال هناك بنايات
عشوائيه هناك بناء يتم التهريب فيه يتم
التعامل رشوه البلديات الامر معروف في
سوريا بشكل بشكل واضح وكبير هناك احيانا
لا نظام هندسي اليس هناك مثلا من قانون
يتابع من اجل سلامه البناء ام لا نعم ولكن
حينما يكون الفساد منتشرا وبالتالي اذا
يمكن رشوه المتعهد يمكن رشوه المهندس
وكل متعهد لديه المهندسون الذين يتعامل
معهم وبالتالي يقولون من سيحاسب بالنهايه
ولكن هناك ابنيه مثلا لاحظنا في الهزه
الثانيه التي كانت ربما ابسط من الهزه
الاولى ولكنها استطاعت ان تصل الى سوريا
ان هناك بناء قد سقط على درجه 5. يعني ليس
ست درجات التي يصبح فيها الابنيه يعني
قابله للتصدع او سته او فصل لسبعه والى ما
هنالك وبالتالي هناك ابنيه كثيره وبخصه ان
سوريا تقض في يعني تقع على منطقه
تصدع صدع زلزالي يمكن ان يؤثر بشكل كبير
وهناك توقعات ان تسوء الاحوال وبخاصه ان
دمشق سبق وان دمرت منذ ثلاث قرون عبر
الزلزال وبالتالي هناك امكانيه لمثل هذا
الخطر هذا الخطر سيتكشف بشكل اساسي في حال
يعني وقع زلزال بشكل او باخر الان منذ
2011 النظام بالاضافه الى الفساد زاد
فسادا زادت يعني تم حصاره اقتصاديا
وبالتالي لم يعد من الامكان القيام
بالمعايير كما يجب حتى حصل اليوم هل نتوقع
اي تغيير لانه الاعين اصبحت ان كان على
تركيا او على سوريا اصبحت على الحكومات ان
هناك خلل ما هو ما جعل هذا الزلزال تاثيره
بهذا الكبر يعني لا احد يتمكن ان يمكن ان
يتوقع حدوث الزلزال او مدى قوته ولكن اقله
تكون الاثار اخف من الذي
شاهدناه والقتله يعني اكثر من 47 الف بين
تركيا وسوريا تماما ولكن يعني يتم اطاره
بعض الرؤوس
ليست كبيره جدا الان يتم التضحيه في تركيا
على سبيل المثال بمتعهدي البناء بحجه انهم
لم يراعوا معايير السلامه ولكن كان يتم
منح تراخيص رسميه بعدم مراعاه ابنيه تقاوم
تختلف الامور الان وخاصنا بانه الاعين
اصبحت موجهه على سوريا الامر صعب في تركيا
قد يتم فرض مجموعه من المعايير السلامه
ولكن في سوريا لا تزال الامور الاقتصاديه
هناك حصار اقتصادي هناك عدم قدره على
البناء اللهم الا اذا حصل هناك اعاده بناء
اعاده اعمار لسوريا واعاده بناء للمناطق
لانه قبل الزلزال هناك مدن مدمره بالكامل
تقريبا وبالتالي في حال تم اعاده الاعمار
يجب ان يؤخذ بعين الاع ان سوريا تقف على
زرف وعلى صدى زلزال ومما يمكن ان يؤدي في
المستقبل بخص ان الامور الان يعني مهدده
بشكل حقيقي بخاصه ان نستطع الزلزالي كما
يقول الجيولوجيون في في منطقه سوريا
وتركيا ليس على مستوى افقي واحد وانما
هناك يعني طبقه التكتونيه فوق الاخرى مما
يجعل الزلزال يمكن ان يكون عنيفا بشكل
كبير وكل ذلك اذا يحتاج الى معايير سلامه
حقيقيه كما تفعل اليابان على سبيل المثال
شكرا لك في الاستوديو كنت معنا دكتور
خلدون النبواني المفكر والباحث السياسي
[موسيقى]
قالت صحيفه هولسي ان الولايات المتحده
ستوسع حجم القوات الامريكيه المنتشره في
تايوان الى نحو اربعه اضعاف لتعزيز برامج
التدريب لجيش الجزيره الذاتيه الحكم وسط
تصاعدا للتهديد الصيني واشارت الى ان
واشنطن تخطط لنشر ما بين 100 الى 200 جندي
على الجزيره في الاشهر المقبله وفقا
لمسؤول امريكي وساقوم القوه الاكبر بتوسيع
برنامج تدريبي بذلت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه جهودا كبيره لابقائه بعيدا عن
العلن فيما تعمل الولايات المتحده لتزويد
تايوان بالقدرات التي تحتاجها للدفاع عن
نفسها دون استفزاز
هذا المساء سنتابع بعد قليل
في لبنان تقارير تكشف توغل القرض الحسن
التابع لميليشيا حزب الله على حساب
القطاعات المصرفيه المنهاره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اثار اعلانو جمعيات
القرض الحسن التابعه حزب الله افتتاحها
اربعه فروع جديده مخاوفا من تمدد المنظومه
الماليه للمليشيا في مختلف المناطق
اللبنانيه لاسيما وان تلك المنظومه
بكتلتها الماليه الضخمه وعدد فروعها باتت
توازي المصارف العملاقه في البلاد وانتقد
لبنانيون توسع المنظومه على حساب النظام
المصرفي الذي يتداعى بشكل سريع اذا اقفل
نحو 400 فرع تمتلكها مصارف لبنانيه حول
العالم فيما رفع القرض الحسن عدد افروعه
لواحد وثلاثين كما حضر خبراء واقتصاد
وسياسيون من ان تمدد ما تسمى بجمعيه القرض
الحسن خارج اطارها ياتي على حساب الشركات
اللبنانيه المنهاره كون هذه الجمعيه
المشبوهه التي تحولت لمصرف يوازي بنوكا
كبرى تشتري شركات ماليه لبنانيه مفلسه
ومهاره لتستولي على مساحات واسعه من هذا
القطاع في البلاد
[موسيقى]
من بيروت ينضم الى دكتور مكرم رباح الباحث
السياسي دكتور مكرم اهلا بك معنا الى اي
حد حقيقه
القرد الحسن اصبحت متجذره في النظام
المصرفي اللبناني
من الاجدر التركيز على حزب الله الذي
يسيطر على مختلف اوجه الاقتصاد والنظام
السياسي اللبناني ونراه من توسيع للقرض
الحسن هو مجرد محاوله لاستفزاز الراي
العام وافتتاحهم لفرع في قضاء عليه في
قريه سوق الغرب المسيحيه التي هي في عمق
الجبل اللبناني هي محاوله تشتيت النظر في
طبيعه الحال ان 31 فرع التابعين لحزب الله
حتى في المناطق التي تخضع لسيطره ميليشيا
حزب الله هي كذلك تبتز الشعب اللبناني
وعلى راسهم الطائفه الشيعيه فما يقوم به
حزب الله هو ليس مجرد مصرف طبيعي هم
يحاولون استغلال حاجه العالم فيقوم
المواطنين اللبنانيين برهن صيغتهم والذهب
العائد لهم ونحن لا نعرف انه يستطيعون
الحصول عليه فان في اخر الامر هذا ليس
مصرف عادي بل هو مشرف يستعمل القوه
والسلاح والغير شرعي
دكتور مكرم من الممكن ان يكون او هذه
الجمعيه جمعيه او منظمه القرض الحسن او ما
يسموها هي تابعه حقيقه للبنك المركزي
الايراني حسب بعض التقارير التي تتحدث عن
ذلك
[موسيقى]
ليس لدى القرض الحسن اي ترخيص قانوني كيف
يعمل يعني كيف تسكت عنه المؤسسات الحكوميه
اللبنانيه
ليش فقط ذلك ان الوقاحه وصلت بان هذه
المؤسسه هي مؤسسه غير حكوميه او حاصله على
ترخيص من وزاره الداخليه ولا تملك الحق
بالقيام باي اعمال ماليه والقيام باي
اعمال اقتصاديه وان كان هذا الشيء
قانوني كان على الاجدر بمصرف لبنان ان
يقوم باصدار توجيهات واضحه للدوله
اللبنانيه بايقاف هذا المصرف والانكا من
ذلك والوقاحه بان هذه المدعوه غاده عون
التي تطبع هذه المنظومه منظومه حزب الله
تقوم
بملاحقه المصارف العاديه في حين نرى بان
هذا المصرف في القرض الحسن الذي هو جهاره
يقوم بخرق القانون لا تقوم باخذ اي
اجراءات علما بان مركز هذا هذه المؤشر
القرض لحسن هو في الضاحيه الجنوبيه اي في
ساحل المتن الجنوبي حيث هي صلاحيه القاضي
عون التي هي مدعي عام جبل لبنان شكرا لك
من بيروت دكتور مكرم رباح الباحث السياسي
على المشاركه معنا
في لبنان ايضا وجهت النائبه العامه في
بيروت لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه وشقيقه
ومساعدته اتهامات بالفساد تتضمن جرائم غسل
اموال واختلاس وتهرب ضريبي وتزوير تاتي
التهم بعد تحقيق استمرت 18 شهرا وتنحى
قاضا سابقا التحقيق ولم يوجه اي اتهامات
كما نفى رياض سلامه هذه الاتهامات مشيرا
الى انها لم ترقى الى لائحه اتهام رسمي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في وقت تصنف الزلازل وموجات
التسونامي كافضل الكوارث هناك عوامل
طبيعيه اخرى لا تقل عنها خطوره وان كانت
نتيجتها ابطا مثل العواصف الترابيه سنتابع
هنا العواصف الترابيه تعني نقل الرياح
لجزيئات الغبار الدقيقه عبر الاف الاميال
وينبعث نحو مليارات من الرمل والغبار في
الغلاف الجوي سنويا بحسب الامم المتحده
انبعاثات تكلف منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وحدها ثلاثه عشر مليار دولار
سنويا كما تسبب امراضا في الجهاز التنفسي
وتضر بالماشيه والمحاصيل وتعطل النقل
ويمكنها تسريع ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري ان
زادت وتييرتها غير ان وكاله الفضاء
الامريكيه ناسا تمكنت من رصد خطر العواصف
الترابيه في جميع انحاء العالم عبر جهاز
جديد عالي التقنيه يسمى اي ام اي تي اي
التحقيق في مصدر غبار سطح الارض المعدني
مقياس طيف التصوير الفضائي الاول من نوعه
يساعد في رسم الخرائط رسم خرائط الوان
الغبار وفهم تاثير غبار الصحراء على
المناخ كما يمكن العلماء بل يمكن العلماء
من استخدام البيانات الموجوده في نماذجهم
المناخيه لتحديد التركيب المعدني
والكيميائي للمواد الموجوده على السطح
وكذلك
انبعاثات المثال
الذي تم اطلاقه في يوليو العام الماضي
يتصل بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه ويدور حول
الارض سته عشره مره في اليوم يقوم ايضا
بمسح شرائط بعرض 50 ميلا خلال ثوان ما
يزود العلماء
بمليارات البيانات لاستخدامها في تنبؤات
النماذج المناخيه وفي وقت كانت مهمه اي ام
اي تي محدوده باثني عشر شهرا فقط هناك
حاليا خطط لتمديد هذه المهمه
[موسيقى]
نشرت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا صورا
التقطها تليسكوب بالجيمس ويب الفضائيه لست
مجرات ضخمه وبعد تحليل المعلومات التي
وفرها القمر الصناعي الجديد اكتشف علماء
الفلك ما يبدو انه ست مجرات ضخمه وقديمه
جدا وهو اكتشاف يقولون انه يمكن ان يقلب
فهمنا لكيفيه تشكل المجرات في بدايه الكون
التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت نذكر بالعناوين
عشيه ذكرى الحرب في كين تدعو لخفض التصعيد
في اوكرانيا وتتحدث عن خارطه الطريق و
واشنطن تنتظر تفاصيل الخطه الصينيه
شريك
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه سيده اوكرانيا
الاولى تتحدث عن لحظه بدء الهجوم الروسي
على
الرشيع
المفكر الروسي المقرب من بوتين يحذر من
حرب اهليه في اوكرانيا بحال خساره روسيا
الحرب
وهسه ارضيه جديده تضرب جنوب تركيا وتقرير
يكشف خدوع 5% فقط من الابنيه في سوريا
لشروط السلامه